Being a mother is literally life's promotion.
Everyone says, oh,
my god, when you become a mother or a tried wife,
you lose all sense of self identity.
That is the most ridiculous thing I've ever heard in my life.
Because no one wants looks at a woman
working a corporate job for another man
100 hours a week and says, oh,
she's lost sense of herself and identity.
When they get promotions and take on more work,
or become someone's assistant,
or get other projects and they work overtime,
and they stop eating and they're high on caffeine,
no one ever says, oh,
they've lost their sense of self.
When they avoid their family,
their children, their parents,
no one says, oh,
my god, look at that boss babe,
she's lost her sense of self.
But for some reason, the minute you have children,
everyone says, oh,
it's so sad that you stay at home with your kids full time
because you've lost your sense of self.
I have had 32 years, 30 when I first had a child,
to build a foundation of who myself was.
And now, because I selflessly care for them every waking second,
I've lost my sense of self.
No, that's offensive.
I would argue
women who work in corporate industries their entire lives
have never developed a sense of self.
Not everyone, but you get my point.
Talk about a biased narrative.